as the taliban seized control of more
and more regions of afghanistan many
women and girls began to fear for their
futures the country's new rulers now no
longer allow boys and girls to attend
schools together secondary schools are
also off limits to girls and it's
unclear when or if the taliban will
allow them to return
for now only boys may attend kabul's
estoqual high school the doors of
secondary schools are now only open to
boys and male teachers
girls are no longer allowed inside
so far the taliban have not explicitly
invited them back to school
[Music]
you can see that the situation in
afghanistan is changing
but it won't exist forever
once the government structure is
established we hope that girls will go
back to
school hope aside it is still unclear
whether the measure is only temporary
and secondary girls schools will simply
resume operations later
since the end of the taliban's previous
rule in 2001
the literacy rate of women has almost
doubled but it still remains one of the
lowest in the world
the education of girls has shaped a
generation
the education of boys may affect a
family but the education of girls
affects society
we are very closely following the matter
so the girls can resume their education
and complete their studies
only elementary schools like this one in
kabul are open to girls
but classes are held separately
according to gender
only men teach boys
and only women teach girls
these girls don't want afghanistan's new
rulers to prevent them from writing
their own future
i want to become successful in the
future from my country so i can make it
prosper
and let's get an update from journalist
france marti in kabul afghanistan franz
what is the situation here the taliban
have claimed things will be different
this time from when they last ruled in
the late 90s but with these reports of
girls not returning to secondary schools
what does this tell us about how
credible they are
i mean then the remains to be seen
however there are echoes to the first
emirates when the taliban ruled in the
late 90s and
early 2000s because back then they also
like restricted girl education or for
example women working
with the with the explanation that the
situation wouldn't allow that and that
they would have to to prepare schools or
the workplace uh that that uh there will
be no problems and uh it sounds pretty
much the same as in the 90s now and
there it lasted like for the whole
duration of the taliban emirates for
five years um
so yeah that there are concerns that it
might be the same again and uh that uh
the taliban will again and again say
they will eventually allow girls to
secondary school but i'll practically
not do that
now we have also heard that the taliban
have set up a new ministry for the quote
propagation of virtue and the prevention
of vice it's in a building that formerly
housed the women's affairs ministry what
is your assessment of that
that the taliban have said up such a
ministry uh was expected uh the
propagation of virtue and the prevention
of mice is usually what they did first
like in rural areas uh to to like
implement their vision of islamic
society
um
uh which is the other this vice police
so that they would do this international
level
uh was to be expected it was similarly
to be expected that the taliban will
close down the ministry for women's
affairs uh they might have said like
that uh
they they will grant women their right
in the islamic context but it was clear
from the beginning that they won't see
the need for a separate ministry and
then it was more or less logic one
ministry uh ceased to exist the building
was there they put a new one in there
so one can't really say that one
ministry was replaced by the order
it was just that the taliban used the
space that they had available
and the rest as i said how they did it
was to be expected
journalist france marty with an update
for us from kabul thank you so much for
that